i will give you a bit of a nudge by the
way um in order to
find out what our constant integration
is we're going to need to use some of
the data in the question that was
provided right
now uh probably the way that i would say
is i would say okay if you go back to
the question
you've got an initial velocity um and
it's also even though it's kind of
implied it doesn't just get like stated
for you
it says that particle is projected
upwards in a medium
and the um y is the point of projection
right so
um we can define if the point of
projection is
um sorry the height above the point of
projection is y then
the point of projection itself has to be
by definition
y equals zero so therefore my next line
after this is that um
when oops it does let's actually write
it when
time is equal to zero even though i
don't have any time variable in here i
have the other
unknowns y and v that i actually know
at time zero so the initial velocity was
30
and by definition my initial
displacement from that point of
production is zero so
those are going to be my v equals 30 and
my y equals zero they're going to be
what i substitute in
now i've got a couple of people putting
it into the chat which is great and it's
nice when you get the same answer as
someone else but let's actually convince
ourselves
that this is the case and um catch me if
i get any issues with
my um uh with my arithmetic here okay
i'm going to put in a 30 over here minus
50
log of 50 plus 30.
those are the two places that v appears
um you can see over on the right hand
side you're just getting
0 plus c so if i may see the subject
it looks like i'm getting 30 minus 50
log 80 on the right hand side
okay yes thank you emanuel sorry you
can't just put thumbs up
on on zoom like you can in teams which
was one of the nice things i missed
about it
okay so i'm always there right i've got
my constant and remember the whole
question was
find y as a function of v and you can
see y
is just hanging out there so once i do
my substitution there's just a little
bit of algebraic manipulation
required to actually get this answer so
let's substitute back in
substituting i'm going to get
what have i got here so i'm just going
to take everything here
none of that changes and then i'm going
to add um
where i'm being exceptionally lazy this
morning i'm going to have the constant
integration that i found over there
and now i just need to tidy up make wine
the subject and i'm going to use some of
my log laws while i'm at it to just try
and make everything as neat and tidy as
i can
so um i'm going to um
subtract all of this from both sides um
because that'll
make minus a fifth wire the subject so
if i make that the subject like so
i'm going to get this duplicate over
there
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to subtract this constant so minus
30
plus 50 log 80 over there on
the uh right hand side there you can see
all my signs have switched around
and what i can do at this point is i can
say let's gather the
those normal terms and then separate
them out from the log terms the reason
why that's useful is because
if you have that v minus 30 right there
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
then say okay let's uh
highlight this term here which is a log
term
and this term here which is a log term
you can see this is a positive
here and then this one's a negative so
if i take out the factor of 50
and then i say well what logs remain
because you're doing a subtraction of
this log take away that log um
the logs you can do a division in there
right so you're going to get the 80
on the denominator uh sorry on the
numerator rather and the 50 plus v
on the denominator so if this is
something that's a bit like fuzzy in
your brain then you're going to need to
go back to
um your log laws to remember that now
you can see from there all i need to do
is make y the subject which is to
multiply
through by minus 5 so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to say yep
take that whole lot there and i'm going
to multiply through by
minus 5 and that will give me y
okay now i have not quite left enough
space here because i want to do
something on the next page as you can
see so i'm going to be a bit cheeky
we have y as our function of velocity
and now we want to find its maximum
height so think about this with me this
shouldn't be too difficult to work out
but you will need your calculator find y
as a function of velocity v done
maximum height happens when you know
you've you shoot up at 30 meters per
second
as per the question initial velocity 30
meters per second
but then because gravity is fighting
against you and air resistance is
fighting against you
as soon as you start um you know in your
upward journey
you begin to slow down and you're going
to slow down up into some point
that you stop and once you stop that is
your maximum height
so to find maximum height what i need to
do is substitute back into this equation
here the place where velocity is
zero does that make sense maximum height
occurs
at the stationary point literally when
you're stationary and you start moving
so what i can do is i'll say i reck i
can just sneak it in
maximum height occurs
when
v equals 0 ie when y
is equal to all right and just have a
look at what you get here right
that term is going to be 0 and that
term's going to be 0. so it looks to me
like i get minus 5 outside of
that minus 30 is still hanging around
the plus 50 is there
and then i've got a log of 8 over
5 because 80 over 50 is gonna um
simplify it to that
so can you go and pop into the chat once
you have reached for your calculator
maybe you've already done it
and you should get a value out for that
can you try that for me please
fantastic yes okay we've got a bunch of
answers there i'll wait for everyone
else very nice that's a
that's that's a nice little i don't mind
that little bit of shade being thrown
there that's totally okay with me
uh so long as it's appropriate okay
so yeah you get like 32.499 something or
other
so i think 32.5 i'll just chuck it in on
the side here
32.5 is totally fine
make that decimal point really obvious
okay now well done as promised i said i
was going to let you now go
and attempt something else with this
question
this is a really cool situation because
we have modeled quite successfully
with a very small amount of calculus i
think in the scheme of things
what's going on in the situation what
happens when it goes up the obvious
question is
what happens when it goes down you can
ask all kinds of different questions
about this but the particular question
i'm going to ask that i think is um
interesting to pose
is well if it goes up to 32.5 meters
right i know how far it's going to
travel down um to return it'll be the
same 32.5 meters
but now the question is for me uh how
long is that going to take
right i don't need to ask a displacement
question anymore because i've already
got all the information i need there
i'm interested in a time question
how long does it take after it reaches
its maximum height
how long does it take to return to the
ground
now i'm going to give you guys a good
like you know
six or seven minutes at least i think to
make some headway through this i'm not
going to scaffold this
as much as i did before but i will just
give you two
sort of nudges in the right direction so
we're all kind of doing this
somewhat consistently okay here's my
first big tip
as per my introduction i think it will
be helpful to you if you think about
this downward journey
as a whole different situation as it
were okay
think about redefine um you know we we
defined y
equals zero as the point of projection
in this first part of the question right
but what i'm going to ask you to do is
to now define y equals 0 your origin
as the where your new situation begins
which is to say
at the top where you have um hit your
maximum height
let's call that y equals 0 let's define
that as the origin
and if we're defining that as the origin
to make the numbers convenient for us
again like you saw in this situation
right here in our general theory
introduction um
let's think about downward now as the
positive direction so if you're starting
at zero
okay traveling downwards toward the
earth we're going to call that
positive so your force of gravity is
going to be
positive in this case we're so used to
think of it as negative but
you'll see why we're doing it as
positive as you progress through the
question okay
so there's the first big tip we're going
to reset um
the origin to be the the start of this
new downward journey so it's
the maximum height um we're going to set
down as a positive
direction and i guess since we're
resetting those and we might as well
reset time as well
let it be equal time time zero sounds
like a trick out of the
you know what is it loki's tv series and
then time variance authority resets the
timeline okay just forget about
everything that happened before
time zero y equals zero downward equals
positive
the last tip i'm going to give you the
secondary tip is
when you go to solve this and you want
to find out
what is this time that it takes to
return to the ground and let's get it i
don't know
a couple decimal places will do us right
you're going to create an equation which
you cannot just solve
just by looking at it or just by
factorizing a quadratic or something
like that
um you're going to need some technology
to help you with this i hope this rings
a bell from like some of the statistics
that you did
you know dealing with say the um the
probability density function
of the normal distribution you could not
integrate that thing by hand
um it's just a mess so therefore we use
technology or tables to be able to read
the appropriate values to get the area
under the curve okay
so you're going to need some technology
to help you with this so i encourage you
to use desmos
um you don't have to use it in a very
sophisticated way but the equation
you're going to get
you're not going to solve by hand you'll
need something that can solve it
for you so i mean you could use um you
know wool from alpha or something like
that if you prefer
but i'm certainly going to show my
solution through desmos
so there are my clues uh reset the
situation and then when you get to a
point where you're solving an equation
for time
that's remember this is how long does it
take a question um
don't be dismayed when you look at the
equation and think uh do i solve that
um use technology to help you i read 806
as the time on my clock so i'm going to
give you at least until uh
let's let's call it 8 13 okay um and
what i'll ask you to do is if you're
getting close to that spot watch the
time
if you're done you're like yeah i'm
totally ready post that in the chat if
you
say actually i know when you're done i'm
like going in circles i'm hitting a
brick wall please post that in the chat
too so i can give you a bit of extra
time
um but right now i'm gonna be quiet let
you have a think have a play
and then we'll come back together around
8 12 8 13 depending on what you say to
me okay
good luck off you go